it is that time of year again we have
announced our top 20 games of 2016 here
at gamespot and now we are taking a
little more time to dive in depth with
our top five favorite games of the year
the last guardians and development for
about a decade and it came in on the
tail end of the year and thankfully
enough of us got to play it and enough
us got to love it to the point where we
have included it's so high on our list
Pete Brown you reviewed it and one of
the things you have pointed out time and
time again was Treecko as a character
this bird dog cat kind of mythical
Griffin ish creature tell me about him
what is it that's so magnetic about him
well I think it's pretty clear that all
the extra development time went into
Treecko because almost every aspect of
his being is believable you know in
relative to video games i should say but
it's the most believable character I've
ever seen be that human or animal in a
game he it's the way he moves it's the
way he reacts to you the way he doesn't
react to you and in his mannerisms are
there so smooth you never really noticed
like him getting stuck in like an
animation loop or anything like that and
so what you have at the end of the day
is his character that is just it
motivates you to want to be a better
person because you have to work with it
and it's so easy to get frustrated with
Treecko but he fights for you at the
same time so there's this this
give-and-take and you learn as a player
to kind of connect with it and it's just
an incredible accomplishment that
they're able to make him so believable
yeah they give and take manifests a lot
in the puzzle solving a major part of
this game that's how I describe it to
people it's like a third person puzzle
adventure almost with this kind of like
magical twist Mary you had talked a few
times about how you really do need to
approach this with patience when you're
going into these puzzles and figuring
out the level design yeah these are
environmental puzzles these are about
figuring out what you're supposed to do
next where you're supposed to go that is
a part of the design of this entire area
and aunt Rico is a huge part of that
that could be anything from you no
climbing him to get somewhere where you
couldn't have gone by yourself or
lowering yourself down on his tail or
getting him to climb onto an object that
you can progress to the next area and
also just utilizing him he doesn't
listen to you sometimes right Peter and
it's like there's reasons for that
there's this one really good puzzle
where he he won't progress because he's
enamored with the smoke and so you have
to figure out how to utilize the smoke
to your advantage to get him to go where
you need him to go next and it's such a
good aha moment every time you're like
that's what I was supposed to do that's
what the game was encouraging me to do
and then solving that and executing it
is just a real treat yeah throughout the
game there's this voice over by the boy
as a much older man presumably by his
voice oh no see otaku no I get a
negative i go to calico 60 adam i guess
for the most onia too but the game
doesn't outright tell you everything it
does tutorial eyes a few things early on
but throughout it's really subtle and
how it communicates its ideas and kind
of unfolds the way it's supposed to work
and how your bond with Treecko you know
forms over that time p can't talk about
how the game kind of tells you these
things well the story that you form i
know as the boy going on an adventure
with Treecko that's really up to you to
you know come to grips with and really
figure out that works incredibly well i
think because it's just based on your
personal experience the sort of grander
story that tells the tale of why you're
there together with this animal who he
is and even who you are that comes in
bits and pieces over time and it's sort
of masterfully told in that way because
you get to focus so much on the
relationship building aspect and then as
you go like you know yeah you'll see if
you cut scenes now and again but you'll
also notice things
the environment where you'll see like
maybe a monument that looks like Treecko
and you wonder okay is this thing
revered in some way you don't really
know by the end you have some answers
you're still left with a few mysteries
but it's great to be able to use both
your imagination and your you know
reasoning and deductive skills to kind
of come to a conclusion the game still
manages to surprise you by the end so
it's a really nice roundabout way of
telling a story without being
heavy-handed in any way yeah the
relationship between the two characters
definitely the fulcrum of this tale but
there is this gorgeous you know like
dare I say it artistic world surrounding
them it's beautiful it really is just
gorgeous and really mysterious men
chanting yeah it is a stunning open
environment that takes you from these
wide vast open areas where you're
precariously walking and tiptoeing over
these thin wires to crawling through
really tiny tub like tiny little
crevices in these areas trying to trying
to figure out your next steps so they're
really painting the world of these old
architecture buildings there's something
that's been around a lot longer than you
have and you want to figure out the
history of this world it's wonderful how
much every time they give you a little
bit just another piece of this world I
don't you can't wait to find out more of
this overarching story in this world
that does not play by the same rules as
any world we're used to I mean they're
just notorious for their world building
and just like eco or shadow of the
colossus this game will just really
enero you with the area that you're put
in you won't you can't wait to learn
what else yes between the world the
characters the bond they form and how
the story is unfolded throughout it's
very bold and kind of empowering
enchanting game and it almost didn't
even make our game of the year
deliberations because came on the tail
end of 2016 but thankfully enough us got
to play it and none of us got to really
tell everybody else about it this is a
game worth playing is our number five
game of the year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]